طيب يا صديقي مذيعه في محطه التيفي واحد
تتحسر على مغادره عدد كبير من زميلاتها
البلد بعد تحولات الاخيره في البلد تقول
ان القيام بالمهام الاعلاميه اصبح صعبا
بالنسبه للمراه الافغانيه
من السيدات وقد قل عددهن بشكل كبير والان
لدينا عدد محدود وقليل جدا
تعمل كم مراسله الميدانيه للمحطه تقول انك
راسي زميلاتها شاغره بجنبها وذلك لانهن
تركن العمل وذهبنا خارج البلد
والبعض الاخر استقنا منها الاعلاميه
المجال الاعلامي من المجالات التي لا
تقرها طالب لعمل مراه بينما سيده
الافغانيه تراه مناسبا لعملها وذلك لان
العمل فيه سهل مقارنه بالمجالات الاخرى
يرى العديد من الافغان انه اذا استمر
استبعاد المراه من العمل فانه سيتضرر
ملايين الاسر والاطفال وسيتعين على الشعب
الافغاني التعامل مع ازمه اقتصاديه خطيره
عبد المنذر العربيه كابول